we can either get our act together which
means to voluntarily subject ourselves
to the Flaming sword
as an individuals or that will be
impressed upon us as a necessity from
without and how intense that will get
we're going to find out
[Music]
I wondered if there's a Jordan Peterson
prediction so if Dostoevsky said
socialism would kill 100 million if
Nietzsche said that we've killed God and
there won't be enough water to mop up
the blood what's your prediction for the
future what do you see
well I I thought this for quite a long
time but but it's more obvious now
will either
subject ourselves to an internal or an
external
approximation of the Apocalypse
and so we can either get our act
together which means to voluntarily
subject ourselves to the Flaming sword
as an individuals or that will be
impressed upon us as a necessity from
without
and how intense that will get
we're going to find out because it's
coming very fast and this is going to be
a rough winter
and we've done everything we could to
make it rough because this is whatever
happens this winter
is pretty much 100
self-inflicted yeah so your hair is a
political reference you're you're making
then about the energy energy crisis and
inflation and and it well specifically
specifically the energy issue because
it was absolutely obvious that what's
going to what's happening right now was
going to happen was if you had your eyes
open vaguely for the last 10 years
thought oh I see where that's headed
and now we're there and why because we
went there
so and we we did that as moral postures
do you see any any hope then or do you
see any anyone with the leadership to to
navigate us through that as well we'll
see you know I've met lots of great
people who who have true leadership
ability a lot of that true leadership
ability
uh is what true leaders do
just so everyone knows
um is they go and listen to people
like really listen what's your problem
what's your problem what's your problem
and then they aggregate all the problems
then at least they know what the
problems are and then they they listen
what do you want what would you what
would you like to see as an alternative
they aggregate all that
and then that's a bottom-up movement in
some real sense like well here's the
problems what everyone's saying here's
the commonalities across what they're
saying here's what people would want
well then the leaders figure out how to
make that happen and then people are
happy because it matches their needs now
that can become corrupt because if
you're having problems you can look for
someone to blame and that's that's the
process that
the left Wingers accused the
right-wingers of uh manifesting in the
form of populism right and I think that
was one of Trump's Temptations was to
listen to the problems manifest
themselves as resentment
and then offer a solution based on
resentment and the left Wingers do that
too obviously and perhaps even more
egregiously
but that's not a good solution
a solution is a better vision
and do we have leaders that can provide
that
we're struggling
for a better vision
and I would say a lot of the activism on
the left to give the devil its due is
also the struggling for a better Vision
the notion that we should be stewards of
the environment which is a much better
way of conceptualizing it
uh caretakers
servers yeah yeah you think the
conservances would embrace it more right
right well tenders of the garden right
keepers of the garden that's our divine
obligation let's say that there's
something in that that part of what
drives the environmentalist ethos on the
positive front the negative front is
something like you know human beings are
a cancer on the planet and we're the
spoilers of Nature and
we're viewed as empathetical to the
Natural order instead of
an emergent part of the natural order
and uh were were obliged to shoulder a
like an anti-nihilist burden of guilt
for violating the natural order and like
you can see an Impulse in that too
to tending but but you can also see it's
War it it being warped in a terrible way
by
by guilt and shame and
accusation and
and envy and
the desire for revenge on God for
creating such an appalling Place let's
say and that's what it is most
fundamentally and that's the spirit of
Cain
[Music]
thank you